let's go from t-mobile to AT&T a
different telecom company you might
remember that we were told that tax
breaks for corporations under Trump were
going to lead to hiring they were going
to lead to economic prosperity and just
really great things for companies and
employees everybody was going to win
because of the Trump tax breaks we were
also told that those pesky Obama era net
neutrality regulations were stifling
telecom companies they were costing the
money they were making it so that they
and their employees and customers were
worse off and as soon as we could repeal
net neutrality everybody was just going
to be better off now many of us knew it
was a ruse we knew that it was lies and
now we have more evidence of that
despite the tax breaks
despite the repeal of net neutrality
AT&T is planning to fire not hire fire
with an F 7000 employees you'll remember
that AT&T claimed that the tax breaks
and the freedom to do what they want to
do on the Internet was going to create
jobs it was going to raise wages and it
was just going to be great for everybody
but it's not happening and it's either
funny or tragic that they're firing
7,000 people because check out what
their CEO Randall Stephenson said during
a 2017 interview on CNBC quote every
billion dollars in additional investment
we make is 7,000 additional additional
jobs we have to put on to put on to put
that capital into the ground or on cell
towers and so forth and these are 7,000
jobs wearing hard hats these are
high-paying jobs with good benefits the
correlation is very very tight if we
have to make that kind of hiring and do
that kind of hiring that drives
productivity which drives what wage
growth so it's very clear billion
dollars AT&T creates 7,000 jobs AT&T
reported 19 billion dollars worth of a
tax windfall in 2018 what
if we multiply out 7,000 jobs per
billion times 19 billion that's a
hundred and thirty three thousand new
jobs but no there's no new jobs with
AT&T they're firing seven thousand
people now journalists smartly
went to AT&T and they said hey you're
firing seven thousand but you had said
you would hire seven thousand for every
billion dollars in tax breaks that you
got in cash infusion they are responding
by saying oh no no no no when the CEO
said that he meant that every billion
dollars gets the gets to the economy is
7,000 new jobs for the economy he didn't
mean for AT&T specifically but of course
if you actually look at what you what he
said you see very clearly that he said
specifically every billion we get is
7,000 new jobs that we create so don't
be tricked this stuff doesn't work it
works only to line the pockets of the
executives and to line the pockets of
the major shareholders period here is
yet another case study in this and if
you have even just a passing
understanding of basic economics and how
money works and how business works you
would realize that 18th he was never
going to start hiring people 7,000 for
every billion and money they got back
merely because they were getting tax
cuts its demand that drives hiring and
giving executives and shareholders money
back with which they can buy back shares
is not going to generate demand for AT&T
services so why would they ever hire
more people on that basis not a surprise
to anybody who's been paying attention
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show we've got a fantastic
program for you today one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
amazing online learning community that
offers thousands of high-quality classes
on almost any topic first 500 people who
click the link under this video will get
two entire months of totally free access
to every single class offered by
Skillshare they've got classes on
everything from design video editing
photography business technology cooking
meditate
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up